genitals
okay thank you so talk about online
vector packing and actually this talk is
based on three papers the first one is a
tight bound for all-night vector packing
and this is joint work with my student a
Iran coin semi chimera and Bruce Shepard
the second paper is with Elon Cohen our
most feared which is also in the
audience and Ellen reutemann which was a
postdoc at Tel Aviv University and the
last one is again with Filan coin and an
Android man and as you can see the joint
co-author is Ilan Cohen and this is a
part of his PhD thesis and also gave a
talk about these PhD theses so if you
have doubts about the following sentence
you can contact me after the talk but
only mostly prepared I prepared a few
slides and they and now in the last few
years there are like a free Trends which
will change the future of computing one
of them is a cybersecurity the second is
data science which includes machinery
machine learning and the third one is
cloud computing so this would be in that
part of cloud computing not within
claiming that these papers will change
anything but still it's part of the
cloud computing community area and a
little bit marketing so what's the
what's the advantage of market of cloud
computing with actually you can enable
sharing of computing resources and they
and the main idea it helps the usually
the companies that they can actually
concentrate on their applications and
their core base
and all the IT part is then there the
outside and don't be too they care about
scaling and supporting the customers I
mean in terms of computing resource and
so forth so this is really changing the
way that computing is done the problem
is that there is some trade-off between
quality of service to the utility of the
of the servers the utilization of the
servers and typically since utility
since quality of service is important
servers they usually operate at a low
utilization and the goal is I going to
discuss is improving the utilization by
signing tasks efficiently and in
particular energy is very important as
you know service takes approximately 10%
of the old energy of the of the world
data centers and their you want to
reduce the cost of energy and minimize
the number of active servers so if you
are allergic to marketing slide this is
this is it there's no marketing anymore
and I'll now switch from now on to the
technical part so I'm going to model the
problem as follows each task requires
multi multi resource such as CPU memory
GPU networks and so forth and and
typically if you put two task which
requires different resources they're
paralyzed very well so if one requires a
lot of CPU the what everyone requires a
lot of memory and so forth you can put
them together because they don't compete
only with each other and the modeling
that they are going to to use is that
each server has a capacity for each
resource and each task required some
some requirement for each source so now
we switch to the mathematical model so
we present it present the problem as
follows each server is actually can be
represented as a d-dimensional beam with
capacity a11 in each coordinate of
course you can say that the coordinates
are different but you can always
normalize it to be one in each corner
and they each task is actually is a 0 1
a vector which is the requirement that
you need from the server's in each of
the different resources and the picture
is as follows here I have three servers
and each column is a different
coordinate and a and now I have five
vectors so again each code you cannot
separate the vector that same color
cannot be separated it's just the way
that it is described it's just the code
the first coordinate it's a
three-dimensional vectors and the height
represent the value of the of that
coordinate and you have to put the you
have to put the vectors inside the bins
so like obviously the blue is going here
it's simple
there already is going here and it
doesn't look the same because it just
sum up sum up numbers you cannot
separate you cannot put this red here
and this red here you have to put it in
the same bin but actually you sum up the
vectors if you still not sure that you
followed both to the exact problem here
is another interpretation which look at
two dimensional vector so the first
vector is the half and quarter and the
second one is a quarter in a quarter and
you actually sum up these numbers and
just to be sure
vector packing is different than
rectangle packing yeah it's not the same
problem it's it's different because just
some you just sum up the coordinate so
this is a problem that I'm going to
discuss and so we are give so formally
we are given a vectors and we want to
partition them into bins such that the
requirement within each bin if I sum up
the vectors they are not larger than the
all one vector
and the goal is to minimize the number
of Bin's so now I'm not going to talk
about online algorithms ever know that
the vectors VI arrive on the fly one
after the other and it has to be
assigned immediately and the competitive
ratio has been defined many times I'm
not going to define it except saying
that algorithm C times opt plus constant
which I already just define it and the
goal is to minimize the competitive
ratio C okay
so let's look at one specific algorithm
for example first week
so the first vector arrives I just put
it on the first vector first beam the
second vector arrives I can fit it again
the third one it doesn't fit so these
two coordinates fit here but the first
coordinate does not refer I need to open
a new a new bin and put it there before
fun again it doesn't fit because of the
first coordinate doesn't fit here as
well doesn't fit here although it may
fit here but still I need to open a new
cordon and you bin and put it there and
the fifth one doesn't doesn't fit in the
first but fit into the second so I
assume it's clear problem square because
I'm going to talk in this talk only on
this single problem so if you're not if
it's not clear then that's it
Hey okay okay so first of all let me
talk about a very special case the equal
one it's this we start the classical bin
packing and I'm not going to list the
result because then I have to spend the
next 40 minutes just to split just with
all the results about people in packing
it's one of the most nutritious problem
it has huge amount of literature
dimension one starting from AFP
asymptotic pitas for the offline version
and first fit and harmonic harmonic plus
harmonic plus plus harmonic plus Minos
plus whatever and a lot a lot of work
and I'm not going to succuss it all so
I'm not going to discuss the offline
version although it was initiated by
Chandrasekaran sanjeev khanna and then
there is a list of papers in the paper
of nikhil here he's
in the sequence so I'm going to discuss
the online version and the online
version actually the first and first
result is the one from 76 which says
that the first weight is d plus 0.7
competitive for D : is actually first
with is 1.7 but for dodger D is is the
plus plus small number and surprisingly
the only lower bound which has been
known is the lower bound of 2 from 93
for arbitrary for larger dimension so
these gaps has been open for a long time
and what we showed in a few years ago is
actually a row bound of D P to the power
of 1 minus Epsilon
information information theoretic row
bound which means the online online
lower bound and the idea of the lower
bound and they I'll explain later why I
write V equal one is as follows we're
going to reduce it for from online graph
coloring and let me define I told I'm
going to talk about only one problem but
I've still will define a different
problem which is the online graph
coloring problem here you are given a
graph it's not known in advance you get
with vertices one by one and every time
you get a vertex you get the edges that
connect the alert s to previous vertices
this is the standard classical a online
graph problem coloring problem and what
we do is actually we reduce the graph
coloring program to vector beam packings
this reduction is not an offline
reduction it's online reduction so you
don't know the graph in advance you get
the vertices one by one and while you
get a vertex you still have to reduce it
immediately to a vector for the bin
packing yet I'll get a vertex you need
to reduce it to a vector and then once
you are you get a solution for the
packing here which is also an online
solution you pick them one by one then
you reduce you got you get back and get
a coloring for the graph coloring and
the main idea here is the Telamon result
which we use is a very cute and
sophisticated low
the others on Magnus Arizonan mario sega
d which show that graph coloring is as
online graph coloring is almost as bad
as you can think if the graph is of size
M then optimum can use only logon colors
while the online algorithm may use
approximately n or n over log n colors
so there is actually a ratio of almost
in between the optimum and the online
algorithm and actually this reduction
shows the same same thing about the
vector bin packing that there is a large
reduction drug gap the optimum can be as
small as rugby while the online
algorithm will be d over log d
approximately and the reduction is
actually not very hot not very hard it's
very simple once you see it you just
need it for two two different vectors
two different vertices that have a joint
edge you live a coordinate one the same
code some let's say one coordinate one
value in the same coordinate and then
you cannot put them together it's very
simple I mean it to be a little bit more
sophisticated but it's not very hard and
then so and then actually in practice
what happens is that ok this is very
pessimistic view of the world you need a
row bound of D an upper bound is
obviously D D plus 0.7 and but in
practice you have additional property
that usually the server's are really
large large capacity compared to the
demands even demand is large is
typically divided into small parts you
never people know don't send huge jobs
you have just divided it dividing them
into parts so typically a task is a
small compared to to the capacity of the
server we if we translate it to vectors
what we need oops what we say is that
all vectors are a at most one over being
the coordinate for example if this is
equal five it means that each coordinate
is at most 25
sent of the capacity and then then we
can get much better result so the upper
bound is D to the power of 1 over B
minus 1 times log it means that if again
if B is equal 5 when actually we reduce
instead of D you get D to the 1/4 to the
power of 1/4 and the lower bound is need
to the power of 1/5 and that's in the
same paper so actually so you can
actually improve and I'm not going to
talk about the upper bound the upper
bound use an algorithm similar to
virtual circuit routing which use
exponential weights
call it multiple weights multiple update
weights and so forth we are very
different names for the same thing and
the lower bound I'm also not going to
talk about a but I'll only mention a
little bit what's the idea the idea is
actually to reduce it again to online
graph coloring but in contrast to the
previous reduction which is actually a
reduction from a problem to a problem
here we can actually cannot do that we
can reduce a graph to a vector two
vectors but the problems if the given a
solution for the vectors we only get
what's called B plus 1 click free graphs
and it does not imply coloring and
actually there is no way to get the
coloring for the original problem but
now we have to actually look at the
exact instances that are used in the
online graph coloring you have to you
have to get into the lower bound and
notice that the instances this specific
instance says you can actually you know
make a graph it does not have a clique
of size 10 it doesn't mean that you can
color it in ten colors obviously there
are counter example to that but for
those instances there is a way to color
with small number of cars not exactly as
you want but approximately the same
number of colors and you have to apply
this construction recursively and then
you you get
you get the appropriate lower bound so
okay this is a picture that you don't
arrest you're not supposed to understand
it's just a picture from the from the
paper I also don't know Joe Vitt
understand it and okay so let's so this
is the things that I'm not going to talk
about and it's already 15 minutes and so
so again to summarize these are the
results is the vector or smaller women
over B but now the interesting question
is what if the vectors are really small
really small compared to the capacity do
you gain out of it so really small for
example 1 over log D once it's becoming
ground verdict there's no so much point
to go below it because the upper bound
cannot be reduced below log D because
this is becoming constant and the lower
bound cannot be reduced below constant
so so actually there is a gap of log or
log D and somehow for some time we
conjecture that the log D is the correct
thing because similar to virtual
circuits routing you know reverse
tougher is like the log D algorithms
which was very natural but the first the
next result that we get you actually get
a randomized key competitive algorithm
for the problem more precisely what do I
mean by small vectors you lose 1 plus
epsilon times C times e when you say
that a vector of small of an epsilon
square times Lobley
and actually we can also do a randomized
algorithm for you made this that
slightly smaller vectors you need to buy
additional poly log factors and they you
actually can get one percepts along x e
you can get virtually a competitive
algorithm and for two dimension actually
can get a better result so first of all
first fit is too competitive first fit
is not good in the sense that it for
dimension D it will be be competitive
while while here are talking about a
competitive so we talked about 2.7
competitive versus
first fit in that bound increases with
the dimension in the worst possible way
and linearly if we look at what's called
restrict at first feet which I'm not
going to define but typically what does
it mean it typically it means that you
don't want to get beans with the run one
coordinate is very large and one
coordinate is very small here is a
two-dimensional only then you can
actually improve it one port 1.48 and
there is actually a four first algorithm
as well as for first row bound I'm not
going to discuss this algorithm again
but later I'm going to discuss a little
bit the lower bound the algorithm is a
bit messy with a lot of details I'm not
going to discuss it that's what I want
to discuss is this a competitive
algorithm for arbitrary dimension so
assuming the vectors are small you can
get really a competitive up to 1 plus
epsilon of course with small enough
vectors so this is what I'm going to
prove now so first of all what's a
technique the technique is based on
first of all we solve this political
model and immediately define what is the
splittable model and then we describe
the algorithm then we use rounding
rounding is by randomized rounding is
more simpler and then deterministically
it's a bit more complicated so what's
the splittable model splitting more
model you have a vector of course I
cannot split to two different
coordinates because that will change the
whole problem it will be completely
meaningless but they can split it into
into fractions alpha 1 up to alpha 4
where a sum is 1 and each vector is
scaled by the same factor so as you can
see the ratio between the coordinates is
are exactly the same as the original you
just scaled down the vectors you cannot
separate different coordinates that's
clear that's a meaning of suitable and I
think that's a natural that your natural
thing and and now for splittable model
it's actually very hard very easy to
understand what the value of opt so if
you take all vectors and so each
coordinate if you
some up the each coordinate separately
you get the volume in that coordinate
and obviously lambda is lambda will be
the maximum among this volume so of
course you need at least lambda bins
because in each bin because there is a
coordinate whose sum up to a lambda and
each bin can give you only one unit of
volume units at least lambda cordemais
lambda bins and surprisingly of this
actually exactly equal exactly lambda of
course ceiling and the way to see it if
if these are all vectors and the value
here is lambda you just split them
equally to equal fractions among lambda
bins so each vector just scaled down and
split it equally between all bins and
then trivially the height is at most
lambda so the offline solution is
completely trivial n is equal to the max
volume of the coordinates and now we're
going to use these two okay this is like
you take any vector you split it equally
these fractions which are sum up to 1
obviously trivially and and this is this
is the optimum solution so that's easy
so now we want to design this a
competitive algorithm round solutions
split splitting grounding already
discussed it the randomized this is
royalty repetition of what they said so
the algorithm will be slang wheeled
slang sliding window algorithm so
sliding window is as following we view
the bins as continuous beans instead of
integer beans what does it mean a beam
of ears written hi in every season J I
is equal to J so a beam from J 2 J plus
1 actually we view it as a continuous
beam from on on the x axis it will be
useful to do to view it as following and
then we maintain a dynamic window a
dynamic window which means between being
a 2
be where each being is actually a
segment of length 1 and any new vector
we split for every vector we split the
we split into into the bins in that
window and we split it in some oblivious
way we don't split it equally between
the bins in the window but we split it
according to some density function and
the deficit density function will be
will be decreasing and I'll explain I'll
give in a minute an example what does it
mean is that if this bin is in the
window you will get the same fraction
that'll get is the scissors is the area
here you'll get the same fraction from
each vector while E is in the window let
me give an example so this is the
density function and these are the bins
so first vector can go let's say to the
first two vectors to the first the first
two bins and then now obviously
alpha 1 plus you can should be split
between this bin and this one and
obviously alpha 1 plus alpha 2 must be
equal 1 because otherwise you don't
split the whole beam and you just put
partially that's been in this tool and
here you get a little bit more and now
when you get the second one the window
is moving a bit and again yes these
three possibilities alpha 2 alpha 3 or 4
of course alpha 2 plus alpha 3 plus
alpha 4 equal 1 and you just split it
among with the same with the same
function so if alpha 2 getting the same
fraction for a first bin in the second
beam scale of course scaled by the wave
vector itself and so forth
and that's the whole algorithm and now
I'm going to define formally yes you
tell us how the left and right endpoints
of the sliding window are defined yes no
okay this is it
so lambda is V 1 again
lambda is the maximum called the maximum
value in each coordinate of each
coordinate then VK just just reminder VK
is just the sum of the of all the
coordinate all the coordinates the cave
coordinator for the vectors now the
window this is precisely answering your
question is between lambda to e times
lambda okay so the window is slightly
moving and it depends on the optimum you
need to you know the value that you know
the lambda up to that point and in the
window is moving like that here it is
and they didn't also tell you what is
the density function density function is
1 over X what does it mean it means of
course if opt is increasing by 1 then
the window is moving a little bit
lambda is the maximum total coordinate
its maximum over all coordinates of the
sum of of all the vectors yes that you
have seen up to now and it's updated
updated over time and now what does it
mean that with the density function is 1
over X it means that the fraction which
you give to pin J which is continuous
bin J is actually a continuous number
between J and J plus 1 it's just the
integral of 1 over X between J and J 1 1
and this is why it's it's LAN of J plus
1 divided by J so this is what the
fraction that you give to being J if it
is in the window and now I'm actually
going to prove this algorithm in three
slides the proof is very simple so I
need to prove two things one is it's a
competitive in the second that it's
feasible so first of all let's say
whitey competitive it's in competitive
trivially because the algorithm just use
Windows from lambda to e times lambda it
doesn't put anything after E times
lambda and lambda is the optimum value
therefore it's trivially competitive
because I never used more rain more than
e times lambda beans so it's trivially
i competitive now second thing that i
have to show is that actually each bin
is completely split each vector is
completely split among all bins and the
way to do it is this is also easy
because the density function is 1 over X
and we split it between bins from lambda
2 e times lambda and this is just the
integral and the inequalities trivially
equal 1 so so what what we have seen
we've seen that actually the algorithm
is a competitive and we split every bin
every vector into the bins but what's
the most important thing is why the
beans are not overflowing yeah I can
always you I can also always design an
algorithm but they never use more bins
and I split all the vectors but the bins
will be overflowed that's that's that's
the main then it's problem but this is
where also not very hard so I look at
being J in the coordinate K and this bin
is getting volume only while it is in
the window so the fraction of the vector
that is getting is this one and he would
get it to the total volume while VJ k is
the volume of a vector of the indicate
coordinate while it this bin is in the
window he's in the window while J is
between opt + E times opt and this is
like the maximum fraction with this bin
gets but it's easy to claim that the
total volume that he would get from
vectors is at most J because once he get
a volume of J we are sure that lambda is
larger than J and then it's out of the
window it's it's one line it's very
simple you have just to think a little
bit about it it cannot get more than J
volume because after that optimum will
be larger than J and then it's out of
the window and now if you just use the
trivial inequality you get it is at most
one and none none of the vector is
overflow that's the whole proof that's
it
this picture is just chase right yeah I
mean the proof is for Jade item k
coordinate you have to prove it for
every item and for every coordinate sure
sure sure I mean this is only one report
yeah this is for one vector one
coordinate of course you have to do it
for all of them but it's the same its
generic pool
okay so randomized now this was
splittable now I want to go to
randomized unsuitable so so I simulate
the sliding window but instead of bins
of size 1 bins of sizes 1 minus Epsilon
so recall that in the in the original
vector being packing if you change from
1 to 1 minus epsilon it could be a
disaster but here since it's fractional
in or vector or small there's no it's
not it you don't lose a lot actually the
optimum just increased by one perception
or one over one minus Epsilon it's not a
big deal
so this is this is okay I mean you
didn't make a big change here and while
the vectors are arriving
you run the sliding you simulate the
sliding window algorithm and you get a
fraction from each vector for each bin
and you just do randomized rounding you
chooses one coordinate at random and
assign the vector there the problem is
that you can get overflow there is no
reason that you're not gonna get an
overflow so if it doesn't you don't get
a real flow we just assign it the vector
there if you have an overflow so we made
separate spillover bins that after if
you have an overflow you just use first
feed and the idea is that the spillover
bins would not get too much load and
therefore it's fine to use very non
efficient algorithm for these vectors so
that's that's it the end the proof is
okay let me show an example before the
proof so here it is you have a this is
you simulate a splittable algorithm and
and then so part is going here here here
you choose one at random it happens to
be this one so it's assigned completely
here
instead the fraction it's a sign
completely here now you'll get another
one again he chooses the second one as a
random choice and it's here now you get
the third one the window is here
although we start to empty it happens to
choose this one in the randomize
rounding and then you cannot put it
there so just going to the spillover
bins so you'd use first feet in the
spillover bins and it lets a whole
algorithm and you are and the proof the
idea is very simple
assuming all vectors are smaller than
epsilon square times log D then as I
said the fact that we decrease the bin
only increased slightly the value of opt
optimum sliding window will be instead
of a competitive 1 plus epsilon e
competitive and then we apply Chernoff
bound and the problems Chernoff bound
that it doesn't plate you doesn't give
you that you succeed with high
probability you succeed with good
probability but not high probability and
therefore but it's good enough that the
total load for the first fit is small so
it's not tiny if you're not succeeding
with high probability but it's not
enough that the spillover bins can
handle the rest and you don't lose a lot
ok now how I'll deal with a
deterministic algorithm so with the same
algorithm simulate sliding window
algorithm and when vector arrive you
compute the fraction of item of vector I
assigned to being J but now there is a
big difference
let JB star be the index minimize some
potential and I hide everything in the
potential the potential use the
exponential functions which are the
similar method to how you proof Chernoff
bound so this is what's pessimistic
estimator as you can call it are many
names to the same thing there is like a
potential function that track the
difference between what you expect to
get and what you really get and use the
sum of the exponent of this difference
and you do it appropriately and here
again it may happen that you assigned to
a bin
and you get an overflow so you need to
use a spillover spillover bins but here
in the in the estimate you'll insist
it's a bit delicate in the estimate you
you ignore this I mean you assume as if
the bin the item was assigned to the
same bin there is some delicate issues
here and I'm not going to discuss it
okay
so you have 15 moment yeah so the only
place where you use the pIJ is from the
fractional algorithm is to test which
bins have a non zero yes precisely
precisely the proof is you show that if
the potential function that you show
that in expectation is decreasing
therefore there is one element which it
will be decreasing you have to you have
to define it's a bit sophisticated than
this I why this is why don't you also
incorporate the TI J's or you're you're
only computing the T IJ is in order to
test for equality with your yeah you
test on it for you don't need it for the
potential but you need it for the proof
that shows that the potential function
is actually decreasing sorry the
potential yeah of course the potential
is what you would expect of course I
mean I forgot the potential is what you
expect versus what you get what you
expect depends on the pIJ yeah I I said
it but I forgot I mean of course what
you expect is it precisely of P IJ so
it's a difference between expect and
reality yeah there's always difference
between what you expect now that you get
and and you just potentially just take
it D to account okay so yeah if you have
questions I'll I mean the correct is the
right person to answer okay
and okay so that's the deterministic
algorithm yeah and just mm-hmm
okay so now I'm going to the last part
so up to now what do we get we get an
upper bound and lower bound only we're
already talking about one single problem
vector vector packing and we looked at
the general case and small
the small small vectors we go to a
competitive algorithm now I'm going to
show a lower bound we are duality and
explain what it is so they're all bound
we can actually get a lower bound for
the splittable online vector been
packing the same problem that we just
discussed and it's not going to be one
lower bound is going to be a sequence of
lower bound which approaches e when the
dimension is going up is increasing and
of course this yields low bounds for
small vectors because small vectors are
in harder than splittable model and it's
also adverse even for against a
randomized algorithm so that's that's a
row bound and okay so how I'm going to
do the robot that is about to start from
an easy very easy case the equal two and
we'll show fur fur for first row bound
so algorithm is a Albu will be any
algorithm of competitive ratio C will
just will have a sequence which consists
of two phases only the first phase we
get a vectors which are 1 and 0 in this
case opt is obviously a and if you are
trying to be efficient you will try to
pack it with small smallest number of
Bin's as possible but then in the second
phase you get vector which are 1/2 and 1
and if you pick this very efficiently
which means we used only a bins now you
cannot use neither of these bins for
packing the second the vectors that
arrive in the second phase because you
need a space of 1/2 so we will have to
use additional to a bins and then you
get 3 a beans while optimum actually use
the whole to a beans optimum is actually
I don't know to describe the okay
because optimum with justice the maximum
over the volume if each coordinate this
is we already notice but specifically it
will use it will put all this vectors
around all bins and then put this
mongrel beans and so so now so you're in
the in the end in some kind of a dilemma
how many beans to open in the first
phase and where to put the items the
vectors so if you you cannot open since
the optimum first phase is a you cannot
open more than see
means because you want to be sick
imperative it means that in the first
coordinate the volume is a and the
ending the number of Bin's that you ABC
a therefore the three volume is ca minus
a and now when you get the second phase
part of it you will put in the first
second phase these vectors of half and
one if you accumulate them all together
it's a into a so part of it you will put
in the bins open in phase one and part
of it will be put in the bins of opens
in phase two you put K here which is
first K in the first coordinate okay in
the second coordinate and the rest a
minus K into a minus K and now you
actually get two linear equations k plus
say smaller than CA this is the this is
the the first coordinate form the first
phase and this is the second coordinate
form the second phase and if you solve
it you get immediately C equal to
four-thirds and this is the whole load
so this is very simple the faux fur
throw bombs are simple it's also tied so
now okay now before I go into the
general case I want to write it as
equations just to use the general terms
X IJ will be the total fraction of
vectors of Phase I that arrived I'll
define a minute phases here already two
phases that it's signed to bins that
were open in phase J so at every phase
in a minute we open some bins and we'll
get vectors and vectors that arrive at
Phase I can be assigned to bins which
are open in phase J and X IJ is exactly
the fractional fraction of it and what
we know is that these things just say
that every vector was assigned somewhere
this is like trivial constraints and the
constraints for before I'm not going to
repeat them it's a volume constraint of
the coordinate one and in phase one and
coordinate two in Phase two the other
two constraints are you are not as
strong and therefore you need only these
two constraint and that's fine now we
are going to go to the D 10 minutes here
I'm I'm completely fine yeah probably
finish seven seconds before so I'm not
going now to have a sequence of of the
phases where first first one is one and
all the rest is zero the second is half
one and all the rest is zero then and
here I'm going to have a vector zero to
eight vectors 3a and eyevac vectors with
these coordinates every time I open a
new I add a new coordinate and the other
coordinate are decreasing and trivially
you can compute by volume consideration
the top tier is a to a and I a this this
is easily to see the top T's is that the
problem of the algorithm that if if he
wants to be efficient he actually want
to pick things as much as possible as
aspect as possible but then he would get
the new vectors which means that here to
leave space in the previous vector so in
some kind of a dilemma and yeah and this
is the last phase last phase is 1 over D
1 over dl 1 and we are done
and now if we define the s just to
recall that X IJ is a total fraction of
vectors that arrive at Phase I and were
assigned and beans open in phase J and
of course J must be smaller than I
because you if the beans are not open
yet you cannot assign the vectors there
this constraint just say that every
vector should be assigned somewhere and
the C competitive algorithm just that
this is this is the only constraint
however you have many many such
constraints so what is just say is that
if you look at coordinate K and the
beans that are open in phase J so
coordinate K
is as a value if we if you just see here
in coordinate K you have here one and
here you have this is one and you get
coordinate I okay coordinate J you have
one and you have J a beans so coordinate
k UF k and all the rest you have one
over i but you have I a so it means that
the volume is one if you I mean what
does it say I mean it's trivial to say
here the coordinate is the coefficient
is K and all the rest is coefficient is
1 I mean it's just trivially two
sometimes it's hard to see in the talk
but it's just translating the sequence
to that equation
so actually what we get here we get a
linear programming very innocent one
this is the constraint that all vectors
is to be and we are trying to minimize
the competitive ratio this is the
constraint that all vector is to be put
somewhere and here's the constraint that
you don't that you don't overflow so
this is a simple linear program you just
solve it but unfortunately this is d
square variables so you have a viable
for our every our n for every I mean you
have here this X RJ is to d square
variables and it's very hard to it took
say more sense but we actually we don't
know how to solve it so we actually
solve it for small numbers so they equal
3 we get one point five D equal ten one
point this and so forth be equal 50
which means 200 2500 Viper's you can go
to 100 would be 10,000 variables and you
get numbers which opposed to point 26
it's not clear we were not sure if where
where it stops and I mean it looks very
innocent but according looking at all
these solutions they equal three for you
cannot you cannot see how the optimal
solutions doesn't look very simple and
and and then we have to do something so
the problem I mean in principle you can
solve you can try to solve it every
solution is a lower bound but you don't
know what happens if these go at
infinity so instead we are going to
bound of course we don't need to get the
optimal solution we're going to bound
the optimal solution and the way to do
it is looking at the do one so this is
different techniques that primal dual in
primal dual you get an algorithm and you
compare it to the dual and you compare
and you get a competitive ratio here the
duality is used to get a row bound you
could get an overall a lower bound
bioptic solving the linear program in
the primary optimally but we don't know
how to do it and but for the dual the
interesting the advantage of the dual
which you don't really need to get the
optimal solution you can get any
solution it will be good enough and any
feasible solution is a dual and and
surprisingly the solution is not this is
T the scaling factor it's not trivial I
mean it has this learn it's kind of
complicated and in the paper we show
some ideas how we get these solutions
for the dual and it's not that it's not
the optimal door solution it's they do
it's a dual solution and the idea is
that we you can guess some of the
variables and then you actually you
write you you look at the continuous
problem you you get differential
equations you've sort of differential
equations and eventually you get what
here I mean when you do the right thing
eventually you get a correct
substitution and and if you compute it
you get the D goes to infinity so again
this is not the optimal we didn't find
the optimal solution but we found a
solution which which in the limit
approaches to the correct solution to
the optimal solution and and this is why
so that's the idea of how to prove lower
bound via duality so the idea is that
construct the collection of imports you
you you generate a primal without the
variables the competitive ratio is there
is
your function you you could sue you cool
you can solve the primal algorithm and
get a low bond
sometimes it's easy sometimes it's
possible and there and then you are done
but if it's complicated it have too many
variables like this Square and score
rubbers then you instead you just go to
the dual and find a feasible solution
and in the dual you can approximate in
the primary you cannot approximate
because then you lose optimality and you
have to kind you have to prove
optimality in the door you don't care
with your approximate a little bit
because you just get just a slightly
worse solution okay so this framework is
used for the e for a vector packing a
lower bound of e it also proved we can
also prove a lower bound for reduction
where nev and Kemal and safely show the
this upper bound and we can show that
this upper bound is actually tied for
it's actually it's a bipartite matching
when the degree is its online bipartite
matching when the degrees D on one side
can we get actually the exact bound and
also for capital investment and form is
to finish seven seconds before so I'm
not going to discuss to this define the
problem but it's going but it's going to
be so I'm going to go to the conclusions
so let me summarize what I talked about
so for the general problem it's very
pessimistic you get the lower bound and
the upper bound so it's useless vector
packing for arbitrary vectors use this
then if you assume it very small the
bounds decreasing D to the power 1 over
D times log D approximately I do some
approximation here if the vectors are
very small then you can get e and also a
lower bound of e open problem this is
the last slide so first of all the upper
bound is d to the power 1 over B minus 1
while the lower bound is little power 1
over B and there is a gap actually the
most interesting case is B equal to 4 B
equal to I know that all vector
are a lot smaller than half in each
coordinate let's say all vector is
smaller than half of each coordinate so
the lower bound is square root of D the
upper bound is useless is it get you
something larger than D so it's D so
there is a gap between square root of D
to D and I mean without without using
this fact you can get e the question if
you can break you can go sub-linear if
you assume that all vector is smaller
than 1/2 that's that's that's
interesting in unknown another very
interesting problem is that when I said
that we have this lower bound a slightly
treated you in the sense that if you
allow additive constant the depends on
the Velo bound breaks so the ero bound
holds always but the lower bound so the
lower bound is the boundaries you
assumed grow bounds is when D is going
to infinity when these fixed and optimum
going to infinity and then you allow a
constant that depends on de it actually
breaks and you might be able to improve
to overcome this lower bound by allowing
additive a constant so this is also very
interesting in a minute this is the last
last thing is that they come okay of
course random order stochastic input and
that's 88 questions for the open
question the third bullet yeah he still
yeah yeah
B no no nothing the better the mean yeah
even if you allow the additive up to the
everything breaks
a couple of questions yes and no
actually not because the low bound since
their reduction from the online coloring
the other line coloring does not work
for randomized so we tend to work here
as well
yeah randomization yeah you're right it
should put another bullet randomized
algorithms yes yes large values of D
like D equals 50 it seems like they're
still an interesting gap in the upper
and lower bounds you have any guess
which one is closer to the truth no then
this if this small then this might be
very relevant you make you might get a
very small competitive ratio for allow
at the tip of 50 but I don't either
yeah I don't know also arrival in the
pouch er yeah I don't know I mean we
don't know even random arrival but yeah
you can ask if so okay when items arrive
and depart then okay there is is what's
called the different version of
competitive ratio one is a maximum
divided a taxi mum and one is the
insaneness the ratio at any point of
time so some things works for versus the
maximum divided by the maximum but not
not completely yeah it's also a good I
also should edit goodbye
giving a talk I can add more open
questions yes